hey guys welcome back to the channel I
read so many books throughout the course
of this video I will be mentioning books
that are
very good some are okay I wouldn't say
too many are bad there's a couple
stinkers at the end of April I read a
book called red Harvest by dashiel
Hammond Hammond is like the father of
you know hard-boiled crime fiction super
distinct writing style the dialogue the
the story just moves at such a pace you
know it's insane the the amount of stuff
that happens in this book and it's so
fun and it is incredibly violent it's
just this town tearing itself apart I
think red Harvest was a huge inspiration
for the movie Yojimbo I mean I will say
by the time it got to the end I was a
little exhausted and some threads aren't
as satisfying as others but it's really
about the the journey and now the
destination shortly after reading this I
watch the Coen Brothers movie for the
first time Miller's Crossing just
fantastic so good but I guess they draw
from Red Harvest a bit and from the
glass key a little bit the title for the
movie Blood Simple the Coen brothers
first movie comes from this book now I
want to talk about a very special
individual a man named John D McDonald
admired by by many Stephen King to name
one hugely popular prolific successful
crime writer best known for his series
The Travis McGee series but he wrote a
ton of really good pulpy novels in the
50s and 60s before he hit it big with
that Series so I read quite a few of his
books but I do want to start with the
one that I read first which is a book
called The Crossroads first thing I
admired about the crossroads is the pros
it's kind of a sweeping story you know
he he kind of does this thing in quite a
few of his books where he analyzes like
a location or a atmosphere this is the
specifically this Crossroads this truck
stop slash outdoor mall you know that
that appears on highways you know this
was written in the 50s and this was
becoming more common with the highway
system expanding and popping up on the
interstates about this family that owns
a section of this um basically that owns
most of the business here has a bunch of
different characters the crime is really
secondary I noticed to a lot of John
McDonald Stories the crime is almost
secondary it's more about these like
character studies it's like a tapestry
of individuals they kind of all converge
around this one crime that occurs and
it's really fun it's almost like I know
it's weird to compare this book to
Magnolia but it's almost has that same
Vibe now I don't want you to come in
thinking this is going to be like
Magnolia because it's not but it it has
that similar like tapestry element of a
lot of characters coming together dated
elements obviously any any pulp book you
read from this time is going to have you
know sexist tropes and whatnot and all
sorts of that stuff but you kind of you
accept the good with the bad and the
writing is just uh incredible I mean you
understand why Stephen King admires I
mean why so many people admired uh John
D McDonald because he he just had a
really he knew when to dial it up in
terms of his that the eloquence in terms
of the the poetic stuff I mean he could
write a [__] sentence but he can also
be hard-boiled agile in that way I would
say that's that's how I would describe
his books but before I get to the next
book this this video is happily
sponsored by wraith marked creative and
the kickstarter for Travis baldry's
you've probably heard of it Legends and
lattes Legends and lattes has been
making the rounds on booktube it seems
like for quite a while I'm currently
reading it and really enjoying it it has
a really laid-back style High fantasy
with low stakes in a genre that doesn't
always have a ton of variety this really
stands out wraithmark is known for is
creating these really delicious looking
why did I say delicious these really
luxurious looking books and at the time
I'm speaking there's about 72 hours left
of this Kickstarter so here's some
pictures of the book and then some
awesome features to it it's a custom
dust jacket with original art embossing
and glossing in addition to that there's
cloth bound case featuring all kinds of
ours these gold gilded page edges ribbon
bookmarks yeah you know colored sheets
custom interior designs and
illustrations and a lot more on top of
that for an example of uh wraith Mark's
stuff uh here's a copy of the sort of
Kai guess this is just a gorgeous book
they just create incredibly high quality
products products that are just
beautiful to own you know so if you're a
fan of Legends and Lattes or you just
want to try reading it you know go check
check out the kickstarter thanks again
with Mark to creative for sponsoring
this video remember to check out their
Kickstarter and the link down below
before the campaign ends very soon don't
miss out Legends and lattes speaking of
books so after my successful reading of
the crossroads I read cry hard cry fast
similar to the crossroads a bunch of
characters but it's all about this
horrible car wreck I mean just these
little vignettes of these characters and
their situations and of course there's a
criminal thing that goes on afterwards
and it wasn't as successful as the
crossroads but it had a lot of fun
interesting stuff and some gruesome
scenes I mean you could really tell that
John D McDonald was kind of scared of
modernity and the automobile and and
then when the crash stuff happens slow
motion car crash so much Carnage and all
these lives and you're kind of wondering
who's going to Survive who's going to
make it but the one real bad book I read
read by John D McDonald was called on
the run this has a soup unlike the other
ones this is a very like simple simple
story and it's trying to be a romance
and it's really just not successful the
writing isn't as solid it just felt like
something he wrote out for money I mean
honestly it didn't feel very fun or
interesting you can kind of tell when he
is getting lazy I think with the story a
bit because then it just becomes huge
sections of dialogue filling up the
pages and I think dialogue is probably
easier to write so it had a really
cliche story and the the romance style
this is mostly romance and you'll see if
you read John D McDonald that romance is
not his strongest stuff especially
dialogue between men and women who are
in love it's just like whoo I mean it's
out of like a 1950s cheesy movie I mean
it's it's more like movie life than than
real life whereas most of his books it
feels more true to life so not a
successful
book in my opinion then I read one of
it's not if not his most famous book uh
the Deep the the deep blue goodbye uh
the first Travis McGee novel it feels
incredibly modern the the way it's
written the it's very self-aware that
the character is very self-aware in a
way that you don't see in a lot of other
crime stories of this era incredibly
well written it's it's hard you can't
deny that when you read this book I have
my issues with the character and the the
type of books these are once I got into
this book and realized oh the series is
going to be like this it's a lot of
Travis McGee as a character is like a
knight in shining armor and his whole
thing is like saving damsels in distress
he is like an archaic figure that's part
of his appeal that's part of what's uh
interesting about him existing in modern
times and a lot of the book is populated
with his thoughts about the modern world
and what went wrong and all you know
he's just an old school kind of person
and also his attitudes I mean I think
that some of the stuff in these books
was supposed to be considered
Progressive for its time I mean you a
lot of crime fiction just shies away
from the subject of men and women in
general but I feel like this book is
very like self-consciously dissecting
relationships between men and women and
feminism and women's changing place in
society you know so it comes across
insanely sexist and dated and it's I
mean some lines I read in this book were
like oh my God it just that's not good
good story it's interesting I definitely
want to read more in the series but oh
boy it's it's a it's a bit tough he's
like the the absolute chauvinist kind of
uh character I have an interesting
relationship to this book on one hand I
love it but also just don't totally love
the the themes that it's dealing with
this is the executioners besides the
deep blue goodbye this is absolutely
absolutely John D McDonald's uh most
famous book because this book written in
the 50s was turned into uh keep fear oh
was this written in the 60s anyways this
was turned into the movie Cape Fear with
Gregory Peck and Robert Mitchum which
was then remade with uh Robert De Niro
directed by Barnes Scorsese so I had
high hopes for this because I really
like both of those movies
um they're very pulpy and but then I
read this and it really isn't over the
top it it feels very kind of like um
cardboard cutout sort of like he was
trying to to play it safe and it felt
very um on the nose with its theme which
themselves weren't super profound or
whatever it doesn't go to the maximum of
what you'd want and it did feel a little
I wasn't super satisfied with this I
think if you're going to start with John
D McDonald don't start with this even
though it's probably his most famous
book very by the books 50s Thriller that
doesn't have a ton of Thrills this book
is called No Room at the morgue It Is by
one of my favorite writers Jean Patrick
manchett if that's how it's pronounced I
love his book The Mad and the bad he
wrote crime novels in the 70s mostly in
France and this is translated they're
usually politically focused and and
absurd in a lot of ways sort of
satirical so there's a lot of comedy in
them no room at the morgue is kind of
his jab at the basic chandler-esque
private eye story and I felt like he
could have done more with it I wasn't
super thrilled with it it didn't go to
the Absurd levels of the man in the bad
or even NADA the mystery was
entertaining enough but there wasn't
what I look for you know in his his kind
of style so I think if you're going to
start with his books don't start with
this start with fatal or the mad and the
bad as you guys know I've been reading a
lot of books by Richard Stark AKA Donald
Westlake who wrote The Parker series and
I read plunder Squad book number 15
which all over the place in a good way
crazy plot threads from the sour lemon
score coming in and then there's an art
Heist that goes horribly wrong I love
the books where Parker he's a
professional Thief where he uh uh fails
and it's so fun plunder Squad definitely
high up there on my ranking and then I
read butcher's moon was written in the
70s this is Parker number 16 and after
butcher's Moon Westlake took a huge gap
uh not writing Parker books until like
1997. uh so butcher's moon was like this
big nasty gnarly complicated crime novel
it's very different from the Parker
formula which usually has four parts
butcher's moon is more like a
traditional crime novel but it brings
back a lot of old characters and there's
tons of heists there's a town it's very
red harvest-esque I can see why it's so
highly respected and it really serves
it's like the Avengers end game of the
Parker series until it was brought back
highly recommend butcher's moon but you
really have to read the other books in
the series maybe not all of them but
you've got to read at least slayground
and plunder Squad and I mean this is
kind of a direct sequel to slayground
then after butcher's moon like I said
there's a long Gap in time when Westlake
wasn't riding as Richard Stark he wasn't
writing Parker and then he came back
with comeback it's just kind of like
straight into Parker doing a job job
goes wrong he has to tie up loose ends
you feel like Parker has been humanized
a bit more over time he's not as tough
it almost feels more realistic in that
sense because if he were a really
successful criminal he'd have to be able
to you know converse with people and
make small talk which before he was
wasn't able to really I think there's a
more of a softer side of Parker but it's
still tough still gritty still
incredibly fun twisty they rob this
really lousy corrupt preacher who's you
know stealing people's money already so
it's just a great classic Parker story
I'd put it around the middle level of
where I'd put it in the series ranking
wise oh then yeah after comeback I read
back flash back flash is solid backflash
they rob a like a casino ship
um not as good as comeback very standard
more like the score or
um just in terms of setting up the
highest planning execution a little
tedious and I almost got the sense that
Westlake knew this area very well so
could write a lot about it in the sense
that it got a little bloated in you have
to expect that the later books are just
going to be different from the early
books because the early books were
pocketbooks disposable you know and
these later books are hardcovers you you
want a little more bang for your buck so
they are longer yeah back Flash not one
of my favorites but it was fine it was I
mean still good not not one of my
favorites in terms of Richard Stark just
means it's still fantastic but it
doesn't hit the highs of the sour lemon
score or slay ground or something I also
read burglars can't be choosers by
Lawrence block I'm a huge fan of
Lawrence block I'm a fan of his Matthew
Scudder series which is very serious and
deep and this is his funny series he
wrote quite a few of these books but
this is the first one and farcical it's
silly it's about Thief who gets framed
for a murder and he's but he's a good
guy and we follow him as he tries to
solve the murder it's it's fun it's just
a ton of fun you're in it with the voice
and really keeps your attention and
Lawrence block is just a Wordsmith you
know he's he he crafts wonderful
sentences and paragraphs and scenes
funny and witty and entertaining and if
you want like a cozy mystery that'll you
know consume your day I would I would
check out the Bernie rodenbar series I
forgot to mention I read Donald
westlake's breakout comic novel because
he wrote a ton of novels before this but
this was his like a comic crime
breakouts called The Fugitive pigeon
really love this book I'm a huge fan of
this this is probably one of my favorite
Westlake books now a nephew of a guy
who's in the mob and he's kind of a
loser he just hangs around he owns a bar
and tends to a bar but it's really just
a front for like money laundering or
whatever there's some Mix-Ups and
confusion and he ends up being hunted
down by these gangsters I mean it's very
I feel like it's very ahead of its time
it has a very modern feel to it you know
what it reminds me of because it's not
like just joke after joke but it's just
comical situations it reminds me a lot
of like the Coen brothers or fargo-esque
it it just had a wonderful feel and it
was funny but also kept your attention
and there were Stakes you know it wasn't
just like oh just jokes and none of it's
serious like these are characters that I
got to care about and really enjoyed and
I was invested in their story while also
enjoying and laughing at what was going
on so just incredible but what do you
expect it's Westlake you know I also
read a book called out of the blue
d-transition baby fairly recent book
really good I don't know I I heard stuff
about it I checked it out from the
library and just amazed with the the
writing it's about these trans
characters who are one of them has
de-transitioned and they want to have a
baby it's so incredible because it's
it's about these characters who feel so
real and specific and I feel like the
book works so well because it is very
specific specific and it's not treating
any of these characters like good guys
or bad guys it's just about these people
trying to make sense of their lives I
felt like it was incredibly
um empathetic and very interesting in
terms of the themes and in terms of
exploring the morality of the decisions
these characters were making not all of
them good decisions just the Dynamics of
the relationships I was blown away by
this book I mean I I feel like in it's
going to be a classic if it's not
already a classic just in terms of
American fiction you know uh just an
incredibly powerful book and then all
throughout this time I've been reading
manga for the first time because someone
incredibly sent me oh Lord this I read
all of this I read Dragon Ball never
watched Dragon Ball I'm gonna save this
for another video I just want to say
that I did read this I also am going to
talk about that in bookmail so I'm on
the floor now to discuss book mail this
is a segment where I talk about all of
the stuff that you all kind finally
generously sent me insanely generously
sent me it's just an unbelievable wealth
of new stuff to explore there's some
self-published stuff there's some manga
there's some all sorts of stuff so I
want to break down and thank everyone
who sent me anything I received a copy
of neon ghosts which is really cool
um I really enjoyed reading that from
Anthony Paul I received the book The
Knight of gnomes first off I can't say I
will read everything anyone sends I will
say I will try to get to what you send
me uh you know just based on the volume
of things people send me there's I can't
promise anything but yeah so that's just
what I say beforehand Knight of gnomes
thank you this is also a very incredibly
nice message if I had a dollar for every
time I hit Shuffle on the just the memes
playlist for my work shift it would
probably add up to the cost of this
package thank you so much for sending me
this book and congrats on publishing
this in addition you also sent me a book
called the Cascade killer which I am
just as excited to
um to read this is a a thriller and I
love thriller so I'm gonna check this
out I also received the chocolate dolls
by Luella Fitzhugh this seems like a
meta kind of story here internet related
this is very interestingly formatted so
I'm interested to dive into this and and
thank you for uh sending this to me a
very very lovely package was sent to me
with all sorts of bookmarks and
everything and a handwritten note this
is called the crystal Shore by Joe
Delancey this is really a beautiful
looking book and I've read of the
beginning and I I think that it's the
writing is quite nice so I'm looking
forward to reading this very soon kind
message all of you all of you are so
nice it's so unusual I I'd expect
there'd be more Maniacs out there
watching my videos this person named
Stanford Brown sent me the entire slow
horses set of books which is so cool I
was so thrilled and I don't think they
even know that I'm a huge fan of the TV
show slow horses which is on Apple with
Gary Oldman this was such a cool thing
thing to get I'm so excited to read
these books thank you very much Stanford
yeah like I don't even it's crazy this
was this was like insane to receive in
my my mailbox you know I also received a
book called The Fisherman by John Langan
I've heard a little bit about this I
think a horror novel this looks really
slick and and good I have been meaning
to read more Horror in terms of horror
this is going to be what I'm going to be
reading next when I get a chance to read
horror someone very kindly sent me this
book 31 days 31 Nights by Ben Nolan
thank you very much a lovely thing when
people interest me with their their
writing I also received these books I
don't think with the note either she
nailed a stake through his head Tales of
biblical Terror edited by Tim leader God
laughs when you die mean little stories
from the wrong side of the tracks by
Michael Boatman I love short story
collections so I'm going to check these
out regardless um I just love the title
she nailed the stake through his head I
love these quasi Daisy by MK bingman
Leica says enjoy or don't that's up to
you I don't run your life and I don't
want to please don't make me from n.k
Beekman you do not have to run my life
thank you very much though just received
this book called how to time travel I
don't know what to make of this in fact
it it seems a little frightening to me
but they said I enjoy your videos a lot
so please enjoy this gift thank you and
I don't know what to make of it but I
will I will look into this
um and then someone very kindly I think
this person on Instagram I believe you
know who you are thank you for sending
me I've never heard of this writer
before uh Andrew Clavin True Crime don't
say a word and The Uncanny True Crime
these two I think were turned into
movies True Crime I know is a Clint
Eastwood movie I like 90s pulpy
Thrillers you know or 80s or whatever
I'm definitely going to be checking
these out and then as I mentioned before
some insane person anonymously sent me
the entire Dragon Ball set which I have
read all of this I intend to have a
video coming out about this journey
because I've never Read Manga before I
found it very interesting and fun you
know who sends someone this about a week
after I finished Dragon Ball this shows
up in my P.O box so I can continue with
the story I mean this is just incredibly
generous even though I didn't grow up
with Dragon Ball it feels nostalgic and
fun and just kind of this childlike fun
just escaping from things I read so much
dark [__] all the time that just having
this um great and also Nadia my wife
Nadia loves loves Dragon Ball so she's
been really happy hearing me talk about
it and recapping things for her I think
that's it I I really hope I'm not
missing anything out if I did
um I'll talk about it in the next book
video but yeah you guys are a crazy
generous
um thank you just for watching this
video I mean this can't believe I get to
do this absolutely insane so I'm I'm
truly grateful for uh for all of you
just I yeah I love books thanks again to
wraithmarked creative for sponsoring
this video remember to check out their
Kickstarter in the link down below
before the campaign ends very thanks
everyone and I will see you all
soon I suppose